you know I didn't welcome to this video
playing wing son wing wing soon from
Germany his brave playing d5 not the
lame c3 mmmm that's unusual
it's a bit unusual to combine c4 and
Bishop g5 j promise that the center is
somewhat unstable as we see em
night night a night move and takes e4
and e5 is immediately hanging okay so I
can definitely just take you probably
take with the bishop I guess I walked he
again going back doesn't make sense so
let's take so he would go if on next and
I would like to be ready to play
he's six quickly taking on b2 looks that
looks wrong so once a tech white center
as quickly as possible
it's got to check potentially only two
so blocking the ephah queenie - now I
think wait Queen e2
okay d6 is not a threat yet maybe
we'd be - I think yeah it's six okay now
keep it simple method now your widest
probably somewhat better these six
rookie one now it's a bit bit bit
awkward really
yeah my development absolutely sucks
I just developing isn't isn't bad for
him either hmm Jim I don't don't quite
know what I did wrong I just don't know
okay um not happy not happy about this
but I need to develop the night playing
without it won't work
yeah night will be good son only for one
or C form that's probably difficult to
avoid shifty for maybe M that that maybe
I don't like my wig back rangam that
that may prove costly my only six
would be one green a 5 mm yeah I'm kind
of hanging on but it is not nice that's
interesting what does that do Knight to
f5 maybe or it's not such a bad square
for the Queen and it could be worse I
wonder if he just has tied down this
Knight to the d6 pawn now I mean I don't
threaten much here that's I'm perfectly
aware of that but I'm not sure that d6
helped him
it still completely sucks on their night
on a sec sighs this doesn't help really
but I don't see a move I don't see a
move that does
a knight 65 who p5 is a pin that doesn't
work
time warning check
he might take a rookie five rookie five
trying to get the seven right would have
been dangerous reason just blunder dead
yeah I had to defend here the whole time
a little bit puzzled by the opening I
mean I don't expect to be hugely better
yeah but Bishop g5 doesn't feel like it
should be that great maybe six what the
engine yes but I can hardly believe that
this is bad yeah but it isn't a great
one that wasn't good I mean it wasn't
ready oh hey yeah he says here he's six
and then in Bishop d6 yeah it's full of
full of tactics yeah yeah here is
bachelor just betcha
now the engine wants me to take I
thought he has t6o
96 no didn't see that I could have taken
yet the position here it's just awkward
I'm just curious if the engine finds
some improvement for Wyatt that is
somehow devastating rookie b1 never they
also look good baby 186 that wasn't good
Jim
look here white is winning it's just a
great position I could be my was very
happy allottee that he played d6 it gave
me a little bit of hope I'm still under
heavy pressure but only later he made
some mistake
yeah yeah yeah I'm still worse I thought
after rook e5 which is indicated by the
Compu rookie 5 rupee 7 this is also it's
just just better for him G for you to
keep the night if I now do this and this
is snack and this is to defend I mean
not happy have it maybe it kind of holds
yeah and here still rookie 5 I just a
blunder can happen with 30 seconds I was
lucky brilliant okay thanks for watching